خمسه شروط صينيه وسادسها حرب اقتصاديه
عالميه ستاكل الاخضر واليابس اذا رفضت
واشنطن والخارجيه الامريكيه انضمام
اوكرانيا باشلاء الحاليه سيجر النيتو
وامريكا الى النزاع هجوم روسي على حدود
كامل الجبهه الاوكرانيه والرئيس الاوكراني
لم يعد امامه خيار واشنطن تعلن انتهاء
التمويل الخاص بكيف روسيا تتوعد بالانتقام
من التشيك فما السبب اليابان تدق ناقوس
خطر قادم من كوريا الشماليه وايران تقترب
من صنع اول قنبله نوويه وبرعاية
يسرع وتيره جهوده لتعميق علاقاته مع مصر
صراع
الاقوياء لقاء خطف الانظار في ظل الحروب
والتوترات التي يشهدها العالم هنا التقى
الرئيس الصيني تشي جين بينج مع نظيره
الامريكي جو بايدن وهنا وضع شي خمس مبادئ
للحفاظ على العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
وتطويرها حيث اوضح ان على البلدين ان
يتخذا مواقف صحيحه تجاه بعضهما البعض وان
يسيطر على العلاقات بشكل مشترك وفعال وان
يمارس معا سياسه مسؤوله للدولتين الرائدين
وان يعمل على تفعيل التعاون الثقافي
والانساني واكدت شي جين بينج ان بيكين
لابد ان تدافع عن مصالحها ليرد المتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض جون كيربي بقوله ان
الولايات المتحده تدعم السلام والاستقرار
في تايوان ولا تدعم استقلال جز جزيره
تايوان لكنها لن ترفض تزويدها بالاسلحه
فهل تنهي واشنطن وبكين خلافاتهما ام ان
صراع اقوى دولتين في العالم سيستمر لننتقل
الى حرب الشرق الاوسط فقد اعتمد مجلس
الامن التابعي للامم المتحده مشروع قرار
قدمته بعثه دوله مالطا لدى المجلس يركز
على مساله حمايه الاطفال في القطاع
والدعوه لاعلان هدنه انسانيه وتقديم
المساعدات لمحتاج لترد تلبيب على تبني
مجلس الامن بذلك القرار بانه منفصل عن
الواقع فيما دعت وزاره الخارجيه العبريه
المجتمع الدولي الى الاصرار على اطلاق
سراح جميع الاسرى العبريين بالسرعه التي
ينص عليها القرار الذي تبناه مجلس الامن
الدولي اكد وزير الاتصالات في القطاع
اسحاق صدر ان الملياردير رجل الاعمال
الامريكي ايلون ماسك لم يفي بوعوده التي
اطلقها سابقا عن ه توفير خدمات الاتصالات
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه للقطاع دوليا قالت
وكاله بلومبرج ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يسرع
وثيره جهوده لتعميق علاقاته مع مصر
ومساعدتها على التعامل مع التداعيات
المتفاقم اثر الصراع في القطاع على حدودها
وفي الاردن قال وزير الخارجيه ايمن الصفدي
ان القصف على محيط المستشفى الميداني
الاردني في القطاع امتداد للجرائم التي
ترتكب تلبيب موضحا ان عمان سترد بكل
الاجراءات القانونيه والدبلوماسيه
والسياسيه اللازمه فيما اذان الرئيس
الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون باشد العبارات كل
قصف يستهدف المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في القطاع وقال ماكرون ان عشرات
من الموظفين الدوليين قتلوا منذ بدايه
القصف في القطاع هذا وصوت البرلمان
البريطاني ضد مذكره تدعو الحكومه
البريطانيه الى دعم وقف فوريا لاطلاق
النار في القطاع وقد تظاهر بريطانيون امام
مجلس العموم اثناء التصويت لمطالبه
البرلمان بالتصويت لصالح المذكره والعمل
على انهاء الحرب وادخال المساعدات الى
القطاع في واشنطن قال الرئيس جو بايدن انه
اوضح لنتنياهو انه سيكون من الخطا احتلال
القطاع وان حل الدولتين هو السبيل الوحيد
لحل الصراع وذلك لا يعني تدخل الجيش
الامريكي لازلنا في امريكا حيث اعرب مسؤول
اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لشبكه ان
بي سي عن قلقهم من الفكره التي طرحها
مسؤولون عبريين سابقون لاقامه منطقه عازله
محصنه في شمال القطاع لحمايه تلبيب من اي
هجوم مستقبلي اما في العراق فقالت الفصائل
المسلحه هناك انها ستوصل استهداف القوات
الامريكيه المنتشره في العراق مشيره الى
ان خطواتها تاتي في اطار الضغط على واشنطن
لوقف الحرب العبريه على القطار ومن العراق
الى ايران حيث اكدت تقارير سريه لوكاله
الطاقه الذريه امتلاك ايران يورانيوم مخصب
يكفي لصنع ثلاث قنابل نوويه بحسب رايترز
ولننتقل الى اليابان التي تدق ناقوس خطر
قادم من كوريا الشماليه حيث اعلن سكرتير
الحكومه اليابانيه هيروكازو ماتسونو ان
كوريا الشماليه تعمل على تطوير صاروخ يعمل
بالوقود
لتحسين قدراتها الهجوميه هجوم كاسح لا وقت
للراحه موسكو تواصل عمليتها العسكريه ولن
تتوقف حتى تحقق اهدافها ليخرج الضابط
السابق في الاستخبارات العسكريه الامريكيه
طوني شافير ويؤكد ان الجيش الروسي شن
هجوما على كامل حدود الجبه وذلك بعد الفشل
الذي لا يمكن انكاره والذي مني به هجوم
كياف المضاد وبحسب قول افادت التقارير ان
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي لم
يعد امامه خيار انكار خسائر الجيش
الاوكراني واوضح الضابط الامريكي السابق
اننا نتحدث ايضا عن المساعدات المقدمه من
الدول الغربيه والتي تبين انها غير فعاله
من جهته اكد نائب مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي لشؤون اوروبا واوراسكوم ان
انضمام اوكرانيا اذا حصل على حلف الناتو
باشلاء الحاليه يهدد بجر الحلف والولايات
المتحده الى نزاع فيما قال منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه بالبي الابيض جون كيربي ان
حزم المساعدات الامريكيه الجديده
لاوكرانيا يجري تقليصها بسبب انتهاء
التمويل المتفق عليه لدعم كياف من جهته
قال زيلينسكي خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع صحفيين
افارقه في كياف ان نظام كياف يعارض تجميد
النزاع مع روسيا واضاف زيلينسكي النزاع
المجمد يشبه البركان النائم وسي يقذ حتما
لذلك لا يمكننا تحمل اي حاله من الجمود في
المقابل ذكرت صحيفه ذا سبيكتاتور
البريطانيه ان الرئيس الاوكراني يحتاج
مواجهه الحقيقه والاعتراف بالوضع الحقيقي
للاحداث وذلك فيما يتعلق بضعف الدعم
الغربي واضافت الصحيفه انه على هذه
الخلفيه ينشا انقسام واضح بينه وبين
القياده العسكريه ويشكو جنود القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه من الظروف الرهبه على
الجبهه وتتابع الصحيفه ان مئات
الاوكرانيين يحاولون كل اسبوع مغادره
البلاد لتجنب التعبئه بالعوده الى روسيا
صرح الناطق باسم الكريملن ديمتري بيسكوف
بان روسيا ستتخذ خطوات انتقاميه اذا اقدمت
السلطات التشيكيه على تجميد ممتلكات
الدوله الروسيه في اراضيها وكان وزير
الخارجيه التشيكي يان ليفسكي قد قال ان
حكومه البلاد وافقت على تجميد ممتلكات
الدوله الروسيه
[موسيقى]
e